the Joe Rogan experience I can't wait
for in Ghana Rosa strike I can't wait
goodness can't wait for that fight when
is that scheduled for which I want to
say it April tickets just went on sale
March 28th March March 2000 Rosen strike
what he did to ouster over his face with
that [ __ ] leaping right hook yeah
when he split his [ __ ] mouth open
that guy is a [ __ ] tank and what was
more impressive than anything to me in
that fight was not that he knocked him
out with the last ten seconds to go but
that he absorbed all the shots now star
hit him with and he kept pressing
forward almost like he was invulnerable
to him I never saw anybody do that to
Alistair he was losing that fight though
I think Alex yeah oh yes Alistair was
winning that fight for sure roses truck
is a [ __ ] tank man yeah he's a tank
and he's a legit 265 right unnatural 265
as is n Ghana so I think this is the
first time in Ghana has ever fought a
guy who's a real world-class kickboxer
who is also his size naturally and is
also a vicious knockout puncher I still
think in Ghana hits harder I think I
still think in Ghana is faster but if I
was in rows and strikes corner what I
would be concentrating on his leg kicks
in particular because Junior dos Santos
even though in Ghana starched him in the
first round and gonna starches almost
everybody out but junior was able to get
off a lot of leg kicks early in the
round and was able to at least affect
him in some way I was like okay this
could be an issue of a real good
kickboxer now we didn't see Rosen strike
used that sort of strategy against
against Alistair he was really looking
to put hands on Alistair he threw some
kicks but really I think in if he
adjusts with in Ghana and tries to move
away from the big shots and chop the
legs he's a better kickboxer he's got
real experience with Muay Thai you know
but he's also a ruthless knockout
striker and he has a crazy chin Rosen
strike has a crazy chin man didn't you
feel bad though for over him at the end
of that like the fact it was almost like
he kind of just jumped up and walked off
like it was a walk-off home run and and
all right like it is like to his face
was hanging off you think they should
have stopped it yes to this cut went
like all the way up to his nose like if
if Rosa strike punched him more it would
have probably fallen off and then they
wouldn't had it stitch up take a patch
off the canvas and wash it off and glue
a better date that he was done like just
find that ko find rose and strike Kos
Alistar over him the UFC does a thing
that I really wish they wouldn't do and
I don't understand the thought process
behind it and this thing is they don't
show finishes online you can't see the
finishes like you'll see a guy pulling
off of the guy like when they stop the
fight he walks away right yes but they
don't show the actual finish what do you
think that is
poor thinking I don't show it I'm
exciting people want to see it'll make
more people watch it is that to get you
to fight pants watches watches oh yeah I
mean look see a flop up but watch him go
down look at that see that stop the
fight teaches does it is that it at the
end of it
okay I wanted it to play out more
because you could see how he's basically
helpless I wonder if they'd do that to
get people to go to fight pass like
maybe if they if we show you part of it
it took up like an automatic promotion
for fight pan I get this - thank you I
can't hanim ajan that's true
I think they fight pass is awesome they
should you know just go to it if you're
a fan yeah I mean it's fight pass is
great and it's not just for fight pass
it's got you know quintet Eddie Bravo's
combat jujitsu zon that a bunch of
different Muay Thai organizations on
that all the UFC's fight passes the [ __ ]
okay here it is look there he's a little
bit he's wobbly there but by then
wouldn't that have been boom how much
time was left when that happened
boom see ya baby yeah walked away yeah
if he had jumped on him and they stopped
it I would get but you could see he died
and touched him Dan touched him watch
Dan touch roses Rex he touches him there
yeah he walked away and then he waved it
off after al store walk yeah you're
right no you know it's a good point it's
a real good point myself maybe is this
the cut was so nasty it was so nasty way
interesting mere seconds from the final
that's why it made me feel bad for over
because if he went down to hit him and
he stopped it I'll be like he had to
stop it right but him walking away might
have [ __ ] him I know that one more
time one more time see that one more
time watch this he's moving to our hands
down gets caught boom gets dropped yeah
you know you're right got right back up
no Ashlee's a good point okay no I
changed my mind
I changed my mind
yeah that when I saw it I was just so
stunned that he caught him in the last
couple I know but it really does prove
it's like you have to watch the fight
till the end it was an exciting way for
a fight yeah I mean it was like
Rodriguez Korean Zombie it's like the
fight ends like that how do you ever
watch a fight for you know you can't not
watch til the end that elbow was insane
that elbow was insane the way I threw
that like a Lookaway elbow and the
Korean Zombie just flatlines you're like
holy [ __ ] it wasn't Rodriguez losing
that fight - yes and then the Korean
Zombie just knocked out Frankie Edgar
he's a tough [ __ ] he had to take
two years off to serve the South Korean
yeah
military military makes you it's
mandatory it's like Israel you have to
do mandatory military time
[Applause]